[Music]
that i'm in the middle
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hmm tastes like hovid oh delicious
hey i noticed we don't have cnn on there
i don't know if you want to bring it up
good morning everybody it's a busy uh
busy day today because uh we're gonna
have my half-assing lawyer in here oh
with uh some legal updates with twitter
been suspended
oh oh no and i don't know it seems like
it's indefinitely
because every time i log in it just
keeps resetting to six days really
good you know listen it's the least
relevant of the platforms
it's the only one i haven't still have
to make it sting will we talking about
that we'll be talking about governor
whitmer we'll be talking about george
floyd we'll be talking about the border
crisis
and we will have rand paul on the show
and i'm going to ask him to tone down
the cattiness a little bit
well really when we're giving puberty
blockers little boys
well you know what maybe you could maybe
we could give him a little bit of
a senator a little bit of testosterone
attack
hey look you hear that voice that's the
hajj twins here conservative twins on
youtube how you boys doing
doing great man you look great man life
is good is life good
yeah well that's nice that's okay that's
great another
day without a cop's knee on your back is
a day above ground hey you just don't
break the law
just don't just seem something you can't
worry about that
and when he tells you to just get in the
car get in the car
well i don't know about that oh you had
to go there huh yeah don't get right
into the car let's move that microphone
a little closer to uh
the hodge uh the the other the kevin
keith sorry
gerald day how are you sir i'm well how
are you i'm this is a disaster this is
terrible
a lot of guests here today we have a lot
going on in studio and quarter black is
here
so we have some news to get to before we
get to the legal update with the half
asian kraken
uh i don't know if you guys have been
following this keith and kevin the
entire oakley school uh
board of california oakley california
because i'm sure someone else is like
there's an oakley local home and
someone's like
me no no not you no no no nobody cares
just like what is it
there's like egypt texas or cairo texas
yeah you know there's a you know there's
a you know there's a there's a place in
texas called white settlement
oh some nice place so it's safe
these are things we can't say
i get to say it well that's why we have
you here today because we're going to be
talking about george floyd and
i can think things that i can't say
so the entire california oakley
california school board
resigned did you guys know why let me
show you because of this
clip whatever i wasn't doing anything
bad i could i really
i honestly don't care about that part
but you know what
are we alone yeah yeah
all of them you're going to call me out
i'm going to [ __ ] you up
having a vested interest in this process
and they don't know what we're
better behind the scenes and it's really
unfortunate
they want to pick on us because they
want their babysitters back
laurel just fyi you guys have the
meeting
oh we have the meeting open to the
public right now
no one can be a check or balance because
they're all dumb
yeah you know she looks pretty crazy but
she's not really going to have anybody
up or anything that's the thing when
women talk careful though gerald she
said
if you what if you test her yeah she
will effortlessly yeah
so that's oh my gosh don't test them
yeah okay that's what you get gerald
that's what you get
that's what you get whoa thanks dad oh
okay you just get your ass whooped
and i couldn't do anything back talk
[ __ ] get shot fam
oh okay
you hit me you uh i'm sorry i believe in
equality
entirely across the board except when it
comes to the military standards and
push-ups
then you ladies can do a lot less
because we want to make sure that we
send an equal amount of you
out into the battlefield to die first
yeah progress
front lines here you go i want to be in
battle okay great do a pull-up
well you don't have to here's a 50-pound
back let's see if you can do the jog and
put the rest of your unit in danger
thanks sweetheart just be sure to strap
down those kids so that they don't
distract anybody
[Music]
imagine we're considered sexist because
we're like no no we want the women and
children to stay home while we protect
them
yeah well why don't you why don't you
don't think that there is capable out in
the front lines
i do not why is that they can't do one
pull-up
[Music]
i rest my case i mean i could build more
of a case but i don't think i need
exhibit a through z
you don't no pull up i rest your honor
yeah
done
not all women of course not yeah not all
one i knew a pregnant uh a friend of
mine eric who's out there watching good
friend of mine
yeah looks like the the guy from the
incredibles and incredibles two have you
even met him
who sells all the stuff and uh his wife
is uh a
very small petite asian uh lady and she
did six pull-ups when she was seven
months pregnant
wow wow that's like a dip belt like
courtney's strong i wouldn't put
courtney in battle courtney's insanely
strong
yeah yeah by the way courtney says
speedy recovery with your surgery
you should see her she just had jaw
surgery her face is all puffy she looks
like every sibling
interviewed in the true crime drama i
never expected that to happen go down
like that he's a good man what is it
with you i don't know if you're stressed
i don't know if that face is trustworthy
i can't do nothing about my face this is
where my face is
what's wrong with the way i talk okay
it's not permanent so it's okay courtney
uh
oh here's another one a judge granted a
motion
to ban comparisons of george floyd to
jesus christ
oh uh because yeah so this is yesterday
judge peter cahill granted the motion
after a witness made the analogy in
there
i think we have a clip don't we yeah
here this is the analogy
um your we would agree that specifically
as worded
uh the court could grant this uh with
respect to the
shall we say parties identified
specifically in that motion
i i have to ask
how did this even become a motion how
did this is his mask staple done
is that a turtle shell ashtray your
honor um
one of our witnesses mentioned something
like this
we do not really
go into we're good enough
that analogy absolutely will not come
anywhere close to being admitted
which brings me to the today's question
of the day again the best thing you can
do is comment for the youtube algorithm
or
some other questions with rand paul but
is george floyd in fact
the second coming of jesus christ
[Laughter]
listen listen all opinions are welcome
however if you answer anything other
than
what that then you're wrong
okay uh hey by the way before we move on
uh you can follow me on instagram live
with credits we have some uh
lifestyle stuff i'm not banned there yet
and this is a live show monday through
thursday 10am eastern that's the best
way to tune in
and next tuesday is uh what is it is
it's march 16th
that's when we're doing the one-year
anniversary to celebrate the 15 days to
slow the spread so on tuesday
we will have all of the predictions what
came true what didn't
which rights you gave up and there's all
of them and
uh yeah well aside from abortion oh [ __ ]
yeah
yes aside from abortion you can still
have abortion up until now
in virginia just make sure you let them
swap you first
yeah they didn't slow those procedures
down we wouldn't want it to be an
unsanitary
unsafe abortion uh yeah be sure to use
some purell on that coat hanger so
uh also send your chat people who are on
the blaze mug club light of course.com
mug club what do you want us to talk
about with rand paul
um this is my question though too is how
do they ban
like the george floyd trial yeah how do
they ban an analogy
saying that it's inadmissible uh as
opposed to
you know actual evidence i don't know i
mean i the judge's eyes were all i
needed on that
i think oh i think that means we have
someone to answer ah
i think we have someone to answer this
question for us
my half patient laura phil richmond
with some updates uh by the way you guys
are still on twitter right
yeah last time i checked our little
brother
let people know that we're uh hey before
we get into the twitter stuff what is
what is
that uh the inadmissible when someone
just says george floyd is jesus christ
because maybe they in fact think
he's jesus christ yeah so federal and
state rules of evidence that govern the
trial they have a rule in the 400s
rule 403 it's about relevance relevance
is defined as very broadly a couple of
specific categories but one of them is
does the prejudicial effect outweigh the
probative value and usually comparing
someone who died in a criminal trial
to a holy figure is going to sway the
jury and not actually be evidence
so that's why you can say i don't want
you to make that argument right
okay is it just mere does his audio suck
should we uh should we uh
shoot a little [ __ ] do you want me to do
i'm going to do this like the old johnny
cuz i'm going to jump in there hey yeah
yeah so here we'll just do it this way
let's get in there do this work better
you can shut off just all right i'm
speaking across the microphone
hello so okay still fine i can hear you
guys update really quickly for people
who don't know so we were
banned on twitter let me make sure i get
this right because i don't want to get
sued yeah
i love my happiness yeah okay i don't
want him i don't want to have to pay the
retainer for that long
right no um i sent a sign in blood too
which i thought was a little weird
yeah so on tuesday while we were live on
air
i was locked out of my twitter account
right banned for 12 hours uh
and what was the reason twitter gave uh
it was blank
right also known as nun also known as
what the [ __ ]
right yeah well now now you're gonna be
banned then yesterday morning
just turn off his love and i'll i'll
work this for you because he sounds uh
he sounds like he's talking in a pool
like i said today's a disaster sizzly
pool we didn't plan on being banned and
slandered
um then yesterday morning the suspension
increased to six days
21 hours and then every time we log in
it's still six days and 21 hours
correct you on that it was actually six
days and nine hours
then three hours later it went up to six
days in 21 hours right
then that's about four hours last night
it just froze
right and every time you would refresh
it would say yes you're still at six
days and ten hours
oh but three hours later you're still at
six days and ten hours and now
finally someone is letting it count down
right
now what was the reason given because
there's three now three twitter
suspensions yep
and look i don't like i said i just want
to do my job yeah right
right but i have no idea do we know what
it is that got me banned well you did
get three emails
and every single one of them was that
standard form email probably a lot of
folks have seen it where it says you
violated the rules
and then their form email has a spot
there where they say exactly what it is
and in every one of those they went
ahead and told you the reason
specifically
colin blake no reason now is this some
is this some legal jargon
that i'm not familiar with well you know
it might be but not in the united states
of america no so
maybe if you live in communist russia or
venezuela where the law doesn't matter
then maybe that might be a reason but
not here i think of venezuela i think
you mean socialist haven
and when you said russia you meant to
say bernie sanders uh honeymoon
paradise yes exactly these people are
running your government hope you like
your stimulus
so so this is this is one of the things
that's yeah taking i'm going to let you
i'll speak off mike because you keep
having to adjust it here so then i'll
just ask questions from afar okay so so
here
we've heard time and time again whether
jack dorsey is in
you know giving an axios interview or
he's in front of congress or he's just
tweeting
chasing his volleyball exactly he's just
he just
took a bunch of hayawaska and he's up in
northern saskatchewan you know out there
learning to get with nature
he says over and over we tell you what
the reasons are
we let you know what the violations are
we're up front we're clear
we uniformly enforce our policies and
that's the way it is
except here it's not just once this is
three weeks now with three separate
alleged violations with not a single
reason
but here's the thing people out there
will go well why do you need the reason
you can tell what post it was for right
no none of them are even connected to
the post
that's it it doesn't even say what post
was the one that was violated and by the
way the only thing is i'll say hit the
notification bell to people are
subscribed because notifications don't
mean a whole lot
uh before i uh i give the mic over here
back to bill
and um oh boy is that um what's going on
hey what's going on what's going on yeah
what's what's happening
hey can we bring something up cnn really
quickly hold on bill
i'm lauren fox on capitol hill and this
is cnn
this is cnn breaking news
oh
he's our intern actually well you know
doc choi it's his son who interns here
um look there's been a rise in
anti-asian hatred you guys know
so there's a breaking point for
everybody let's be sure to check on him
though wait for the facts
okay so bill uh um
is this is this also in line with the
law and again twitter's own practices
but
legally where does this line up if they
don't give a reason so this is exactly
the point we've been making with other
tech platforms you all can set the rules
however you want to set them but if
you're going to
advertise and draw in consumers from the
entire united states
the entire world creators people who are
advertising and say we enforce our
policies in a certain way
and then you don't actually follow your
own rules that is anti-competitive
you've got one media company
trying to hurt another media company and
it's deceptive literally consumers are
out there going
hey uh no no they don't ban people
without giving reasons they don't uh
enforce twitter suspensions and then
reset the clock seven different times in
a 24-hour period without saying anything
who would do something twitter would do
something twitter is doing that
something right now
yeah but just like uh well i can't i got
to be careful because you're here
yeah um what have you you said that jack
dorsey was trying to get with nature
okay listen that's a layup that's a
layup for an analogy of him stopping a
moose and of course we don't mean it
that's a that's a hard stop well i i
especially in running slowly
here's these things the moose is an
innocent victim in all of you that's
right you know exactly
let's just be clear okay i don't want to
you know put consent on the moose when
the moose says no exactly
can't consent so what have you done uh
since i pay you so much what have we
done
at this point because it doesn't feel
good for me right so here's a couple of
things so let's go back to the one that
was three weeks ago which feels like a
million years ago at this point
where they actually shortened the ban
after we sent a notice they didn't
respond they didn't say
oh actually here's where you violated
they didn't do any of that stuff they
just said
oh okay we'll shorten the the 12-hour
ban
now this time around we've sent multiple
legal notices we've went through every
platform appeal that's available right
this is what they say they go
well there's always a way to be able to
appeal it within the system no
not actually true but we went through
and we found other ways to be able to do
it we've contacted the legal department
directly we've contacted the trust and
safety department actually
directly and to this moment until right
before on air still
no response at all they haven't even
given us the reason
right at all bill are they outsourcing
like to the same customer service team
that facebook uses because
they do the exact same things they just
don't get in the back with you they
don't give you reasons for suspension
it might be i mean it could be it could
be a call a call center in omaha it
could be a call center
in calcutta nobody knows where they're
actually subbing these out it's like
all big tech they're right they all
exactly and every time they do one of
these things they go well you know a sub
of a sub of a subcontractor
gave it to his cousin's dog and like he
hit the wrong button right but they did
this same thing
with a sitting president they've done
this thing across the board
they've had multiple instances of their
inability to handle
the kind of issues that are endemic to
having a large platform
essentially what they're proving day in
and day out is that they can't
uphold their own policies at scale which
means if they can't
hold the power responsibly they can't
have the power they need to be held
responsible
this kind of bad faith action is exactly
what isn't protected by section 230.
right hey can i say something yeah yeah
yeah um
what five days ago we got hodge twins tv
right
list and never explained to us which
video of violet problems
no this is harsh twins tv vimeo it was a
pay-per-view channel
well leave it uh you know it's the
stereotype of the angry black man
they're still
it takes a while for them to be
deprogrammed even at vimeo
yeah they wouldn't hurt a fly one of
those albino flights
they're creative yeah a rooftop korean
see what happens
yeah that's dangerous yeah and they they
won't tell us exactly what
we did they just said you're bad people
well listen don't give them an argument
they wouldn't use your defense no yeah
right
so what is the 230 thing here's this is
the thing look because you have all
these conservatives who they
live for just they just want to oh i was
look i was banned i was i've not been
banned i've been suspended and we've
obviously we've had people who've
committed actual slander liable on
twitter with you know people uh
photoshopping swastikas accusing me of
everything under the sun right and
nothing gets done it doesn't get done
for a long
time and then you get locked out i get
locked out um
i want to know what the rules are like
with youtube for example we said okay
what are the rules and the rules aren't
what
we initially thought the rules to be
because then they created two three four
sets of guidelines now youtube has
community guideline violations they have
advertiser friendly guidelines
and then they have borderline content
well who determines that nobody really
knows
it's not really told but at least they
have some kind of a vague page
and they do answer there is an appeal
process i would say this with youtube
with the appeal process
it sucks when like no this is hate
speech but they tell you
right twitter doesn't give any kind of a
reason so my point is look with this
they can do it to someone like me and
i'm i don't want to
but i'm not going to self censor to the
point of of
you know being dishonest on twitter and
so if i end up losing it because i say
look happy international women's day i'm
celebrating the brave and beautiful
trans women of saudi arabia
if that's the reason then they should
take it up with saudi arabia who by the
way twitter bans my tweets in saudi
arabia sometimes
because it offends the islamic
sensibilities saudi arabia i mean the
number of notices we get that are about
reviews this is the thing germany is
german germany all the time
i mean there's we're at least at 25
different countries
that twitter has somehow found a way to
actively and instantly determine whether
or not it's violating
those countries laws but yet they cannot
figure out a way
to let an american citizen for an
american company know
what was the post that created an
alleged violation
or even what the reason was this is what
i'm saying
over and over again is that these
companies have developed and created for
themselves
so much power that they're unable to
actually exercise it in good faith they
simply can't they can't even enforce
their own rules
or not enforce them in the right way
they've entrusted it to ai
to robots to subcontractors every
instance and this isn't just
conservatives this is happening to
people across the board
and yet nothing is being done to
actually curb that weather in congress
certainly not happening under this
administration but also the question of
the courts and if some
someone's going to have to step up we're
doing that action as well but twitter
itself is now one of the ones that is
the most egregious on this front and i
don't think jack dorsey in hiawasca is
going to do anything about it
i don't know well it depends that moose
might have some leverage
hey look at this picture of you mounting
me
it's the same evidence i've always had
um
so i just tweaked it a little
uh here's the thing what can be done for
people who were old enough to watch
rocking both
well yeah yeah that's classic by the way
everybody rocky was rocky was
yeah he lead us you shouldn't look at
that lady in that dress
i have rock hard hitler's rookie
and then boris and natasha the commies
coming in tying people to train tracks
that wasn't some sick role-playing
classic dudley do right you've been a
you've been a you've been a mountie
for 12 years you don't know how to get
on a horse not backwards
it's difficult i'm [ __ ] now
so the best way really the best way at
this point is you've got to vote with
your clicks
your tweets everything else like that
whether you're sending a message
it's continuing to share stuff that they
don't want to be shared share it as much
as you can
go ahead and like those folks who are
doing it or go find them on other
platforms
i mean just the simple existence of mug
club or other platforms that are making
this happen
whether it's parlor your rumbles or
other other things like that
they're where the advertiser going wait
a minute this is not an effective
strategy
the only thing that apparently matters
to them is their pocketbook that's the
only thing they're going to listen to
and we can affect it every one little
tweet maybe not by itself
but all of them together so while we're
taking the fight on the legal side
folks can take that side whether they're
sitting at home whether they're in their
grandma's basement whether they're at
the bus station doesn't matter you can
get on those apps
and make your voice heard i think it's
important too for everyone out there to
understand section 230 was very
interesting twitter
sued uh texas a g paxton and they said
that a.g paxton
was leveraging them to try and infringe
on their their exact words editorial
decisions
regarding what is on editorial they use
the word editorial
so my question is at that point how does
that how does how do we juxtapose that
with 230. explain to people i know we've
described this ad nauseam but the reason
that these platforms are not held liable
at all
so is because of 230 which if the new
york times for example
just uh puts up something they're held
responsible right slander like it says
like hey
gerald uh you know gerald beat me up in
a bathroom stall with george michael
right if some of the new york times
writes that they can be held responsible
right someone puts it up on twitter
well they're not held responsible at all
because of section 230 but then they
in their own lawsuit say well no one can
infringe on our editorial guidelines and
it's all opaque
well it's it's one of the best analogies
is are you going to hold the att libel
if a criminal decides to call on a cell
phone that goes across
an att line right you're going to say no
this is utility just because the city
provided water was the city
now liable for the fact that that water
was used to make the best meth in the
country no not at all
so what we're looking at now is the
question of are you more
like there's a reason that great lakes
still has the crown for meth
great great lakes water meth the ph
is on point but what is what are they
now closer to
does it does att does the water company
do they exercise
editorial functions do they selectively
decide on a on a
guideline basis who are going to be
their customers no you sign up you pay
the bill you're in
but when you look at the new york times
they look
they edit they decide they cut they
allowed
they have guidelines for what they're
going to put on there they have whole
teams that are doing that
and that's when you now look at what
it's more of these platforms what are
they more like are they more like the
utility
that's letting anyone go say anything
they want and we're just
providing the vehicle for it or are you
coming in and actually exercising
editorial function
use their own words exactly like you
said this again isn't about
we're telling you how to run your
business this isn't saying the
government should come in and run your
business
it's run your business in an honest way
and if you were honestly
editing you're honestly held liable for
it right exactly yeah
now look i don't want and gerald you
have a question well the analogy
actually gets worse stephen like you
said with the new york times but twitter
with the moose
it gets even worse so it's like the new
york times putting out that story and
then blocking my account
the twitter blocking my account and
saying you can't
right that's what happens and they can
just
twitter blocked your account no no no
i'm saying
it would be like that he always gets
screwed
[Laughter]
i would believe it i would believe it
they blocked your account no no no no no
i'm saying that that's what it would be
like it's like the new york times
tweeting out a story about me that's
false that i should be able to sue them
over and then twitter
locking me out of my account so that i
can't defend myself right
right that's exactly what it's like
that's what twitter is doing when they
block people for oh 12 hours oh it's
just a couple of days oh we'll fix the
problem
no this is strategic you're doing this
stuff on purpose yeah
or at least it's very coincidental look
uh have asianville i know you have to
get going
my final question here is look i don't
want to because
please join my club i don't have um we
don't like getting banned
i don't want to have to sue twitter
we're doing the facebook lawsuit which i
know
we we can't do we can't give you a bunch
of updates right now but the wheels are
in motion
um what do we do with twitter what are
we gonna
what's everything on the table so
everything's on the table
all of the options are available but
this is this is i will tell you and and
most good lawyers will admit that
the legal system should be the last
resort and unfortunately twitter is
essentially pushing us to say
you better go to the last resort because
congress doesn't do anything there are
the president's not doing anything not
going to do anything
the vice president is really in power
isn't going to do anything the state
legislatures may they're trying you
still look at these various states
that are trying to enact legislation to
try and do something about it thank god
that they're doing that
but really ultimately we're going to
have to figure out all the ways we can
do it speaking of i'm going to get out
of here to go work on it i got to go
suit up go shoot up do it
thank you have for you i have a bill i
have music
[Music]
okay sorry he's got to go suit up yeah
okay
hey bill what's going on you just told
steve and you're
going to suit up you already had a suit
on
for the whole show yeah when when you're
in a battle with big tech
you got to have the best protection out
there there's only one name i trust
spartan body armor they're the leader in
ceramic
steel concealable rifle rated most of
their products are nij certified which
is the best certification out there
and uh you know when you've got a target
this big on your back
you got to make sure it's protected
well that's true that's nice and by the
way they are a wonderful sponsor uh if
you go to spartanarmorsystems.com
uh enter the promo code crowder you get
10 off
it really is one of the most trusted and
by the way this thing is so light
yeah up to 44 magnum almost can't even
tell proof that's 44
yeah and people don't even know that uh
i've worn sometimes i wear it and you
can't even see it
people just say damn he looks jacked
it's like nah that's a spartan armor
underneath my shirt
why do you sleep in it though that's
that's odd that's comfy i find the
feeling of kevlar against my skin
incredibly erotically ah it's like jack
dorsey with moose
that way do you guys have any of the
body armor stuff
no yeah we can send you some yeah yeah
i'd love to have yeah especially you
guys know the right you guys need it
yeah um yeah yeah listen they can
i don't understand how some legislation
legislative bodies want to ban something
that's defensive
yeah it doesn't want to ban that oh yeah
it's been banned if in many places yeah
yeah
for what defending yourself it's scary
when they see you walking around with
this you must be up to no good yeah
i think their argument is that it makes
you um it makes you
more capable of inflicting damage
without
receiving it okay uh i think that's the
argument
so it needs to be like a gentleman's
duel each person can
die right with the cops who you
shouldn't trust but you should call
because you're not allowed a gun
when someone is uh raping you that's
definitely they also get the vest
by the way not you police response times
are they
vary across the country yeah but one of
the best police response times that i
know of was in el segundo california
when i lived there and it was like a
minute and a half
which sounds really good little known
fact when you're being raped brutally
and repeatedly
a minute and a half feels like a
lifetime oh yeah
in eternity that is a long minute and a
half
yeah spartan armor systems.comment to
the promo code crowder
okay uh the head of borders this is
another story here the head of border
security before we get to rand paul and
again people on mug club send in your
questions what are you kicking your
brother what's going on he just told me
to wake up
i'm like yeah i asked you when you came
if you needed some caffeine
i'm awake and you said i got some crack
coke over here
whoa whoa no come on got some coke we do
no no we do meth okay you guys do crack
that's right and then we all do hair i
want the white man's stuff all in the
good stuff
to cocaine oh no damn crap no no
no no no no no no meth is not the good
stuff it's not cleaner than crack it's
just that the poor white man is more
responsible with his money
well it doesn't care about his teeth
very much it doesn't care about his
teeth at all yeah no
exactly very english of you western
price so
um trump uh to biden has been trending
everywhere
and we want to get to whitmer in a
second then rand paul which i'm really
looking forward to
uh but uh the head of border security is
the head of border security i don't know
roberta jackson i see
this person all the time claimed that
the border crisis is because of trump's
lack of humanity which was discouraging
people from coming which by the way
listen before i even get to the next
part
i'm okay with um and then
later in the clip though she went on to
admit that
it actually was biden's fault and i know
you think that i'm making this up so i
have the clip
right now over roberta jackson uh
sandwiched together
it's a coincidence that as soon as trump
and his immigration policy were
on the way out and biden and his stated
policy were on the way in this
historic surge at the border started
well first of all one of the things i
think is important is we've seen surges
before
surges tend to respond to hope
and there was a significant heart
for a more humane policy after
four years of you know pent up demand
so i don't know whether i would call
that a coincidence but i certainly think
that
the idea that a more humane policy would
be in place
may have driven people to make that
decision
but perhaps more importantly it
definitely drove smugglers
to express
disinformation to spread distance that's
the moment where she realizes it is now
possible
and we know that if the change in
administrations brought hope
then from your perspective is this surge
good
i don't think that's what i just
feel at a particular time you see that
lady by the way that's unfortunate
you know what i've watched and i i i
don't always watch the clips i read a
lot of the time so sometimes i don't see
the clips of these people
but that's roberta jackson right head
it's actually jacobson that was a typo
jacobson
sorry that's right why was i saying
jackson that was me i don't know i got
two black guys here jackson's a common
name
stop it he's gonna mix it up it's not
even a joke didn't we uh wouldn't i pick
out an o lineman and steven knows sports
yeah
by just saying jackson i don't i said uh
uh marcus
jackson i was like name me one nfl and i
just said let me pick
the name of a large 350-pound black man
with an
under 540 and marcus jackson is actually
a person yeah so that's what i was
thinking of unbelievable
um it's not racist i would have went
with tyrone jackson
well yeah with a soccer player too right
with silva yeah
thiago silva but no that was so i just i
just watched that clip for the first
time and i realized
you know it's unfortunate but i did
recognize her from somewhere
you know thankfully we're in a good
position still fiscally speaking
oh there you go geez some turkey
actually
[Music]
so this is what's great about this by
the way and this is a you know what
comment question
another question of the day of course is
george floyd jesus christ yeah
but another one here is uh let's say
because donald trump when they say was a
lack of compassion right but what's the
lack of compassion
it's people it's referring to these
countries for example as
[ __ ] countries right yeah yeah and
that was considered racist but then we
say
look there's this pent-up demand hold on
a second wait wait wait jacobson
pent up demand pent up demand from what
yeah why would there be pent up demand
if they don't live in [ __ ] countries
right there would be no pent up demand
to leave them so they said okay that's
racist and then donald trump said well
look you're saying they're not [ __ ]
they're not [ __ ] countries let's
send them back
let's not allow them to come in here in
record numbers what's a lack of
compassion
putting up a border wall enforcing our
own immigration laws
like every other country you want to
find out who's really nationalistic and
racist go down to mexico ask them how
they feel about hondurans and el
salvadorians yeah
can we build them no no no no no no no
did you build a wall we don't have money
we shoot them
sometimes we just put we put landmines
on the road so
we blow them up in there right
it's with the caravan he's kind of boom
since when were you supposed to give
people breaking the law hope
yeah when was that but like ucl i see
hope
yeah exactly it's like bank robbers
going in and now there's a lot of bank
robberies now and oh well that's
actually because we removed all of the
security features and i guess it gave
them hope that they would make it out
alive with money
yeah back to you on your cash register
all right he thinks me seeing a dreamer
over there
ow you're a rascal little [ __ ]
got a bright future i'm just so i'm just
so fed up with this i think it's hope
and humanity really okay so what's the
hope now the hope and by the way you're
putting more
people in cages record numbers i saw
that i think yesterday
unbelievable i don't know when it became
considered racist facilities when it
became considered inhumane
to simply send people back disney el
paso
to their non-shithole country to their
wonderful country
which by the way sees the same record
number of would-be migrants two places
like mexico
because it's a shining beacon of hope
for all to see
you know what stephen it's beautiful we
had a show in the united kingdom we was
on immigration hole for two hours
they put us in cages and everything
right rightfully we actually had to pay
like
1800 some odd dollars we had two show
schedules yeah
sold out i was coming from the united
states the united states is not a
[ __ ]
we went there and they said we had the
right visa detroit yeah yeah
so they needed a visa yeah our visa
wasn't correct
we had to pay 1800 just to be able to
stay to do our shows yeah
even though we're sitting beside each
other we couldn't talk to each other
really
what what is this how did that happen i
don't know
did they put like glass up between you
no we're just sitting there looking at
you like
okay he's not looking what are we going
to do
what did they think you guys were
islamic no
did you have the beard they knew who we
were they said they were fans
they said that we was going to stay in
that country and get on wherefore i was
like you people are so rich
yeah we had to sign documents saying we
was not going to stay and
get on that warfare listen you're
welcome to stay in our country life so
long as you don't marry into the royal
family and please let's just say we're
not
speaking with each other we don't need
any chance of allah by the way mecca's
that way we don't need any black babies
in this room aren't you a gorgeous bit
of dark chocolate
you little cadbury eggs sign this here
here saying you want to drain on our
system as many minorities
it's okay to say here in the uk we don't
have as many blacks
i experience that's that crap in canada
too you people don't realize this in
canada in in quebec
they're racist well you people they're
very racist you people
wait what do i mean by you say you
people i meant
i mean black people no no with with
french canadians you people so they are
race they are racist with black people
with all black people i am trying to say
french canadians are often very racist
now they're not racist in the sense that
they hate black people
they're just racist in the sense that
it's okay to stereotype so they'll be
like
you'll be sitting you'll be talking with
them and i'm like hey man you americans
you're so racist
you're so racist that's the problem
you're like yeah yeah no listen
i think that's horrible it's wrong to to
hate you know everybody
uh has to be equal yep yep and blacks
are lazy as [ __ ] man like you know
i'm like writing the next joke i swear
to you so there's the length that
that league long i think is what it's
called people can fact check me that we
have some montreal fans there who
want to get out sorry i can't get you
all on work visas yeah but no caravan
coming from there so they have the
language police in canada people
understand this
when people talk about discrimination in
the united states i say well you know i
faced some systemic discrimination in
canada
what do you mean you're white i go it's
a french province in an english country
where i was forced to go to french
schools just because my mom was born in
quebec if you have one parent born in
quebec
you have to go to french school they
thought i was learning disabled until
through a loophole i was allowed to
learn geography and math
in english thank goodness if i wanted to
open stephen's diner apostrophe s
i would be fined out of existence
because it's not french right so they
call this thing purelen
is the term that literally translates to
pure wool
purity test racial purity where they
only want pure
european blooded french people sounds
like nazi germany right well
it's not really close it's not you know
the worst is you get some looks and
someone
someone with a some a rat tail you know
it's on youtube get out man
go up there to gaspe with the moose and
jack garcia okay we know
gonna have a spit rolls you too so um
then what happened is they created this
because they were trying to expel all
the english people
from quebec and so a bunch of haitian
people sort of migrating to quebec
because they're french and they're like
oh yes no man we can't have that
so then they started trying to get rid
of the haitians there goes the
neighborhood
yeah oh hell man i don't want people
from how you call it that uh [ __ ] old
country
we don't want that they're just seeking
asylum
yeah yeah yeah dreamers hey yeah you two
hate me you come here me too i'll seek
asylum because
all the haitian dorky gonna make me
crazy man
and they don't realize it's racist yeah
anyway
uh speaking of uh speaking of this right
now the the uh disaster at the border
trump responded
i missed that man already yeah i know
his responsibility so this is his
response yesterday here let me take a
little bit of when is uh
senator rand paul going to be coming
it'll be soon right uh yeah in about 20
minutes twelve twenty minutes okay so we
can do our whitmer
segment and by the way send in your uh
your questions for rand paul
so yesterday president trump released
this i think
he said i hope every i hope everyone
remembers when they're getting
the covid19 parentheses often referred
to
as the chinese virus
[Laughter]
vaccine that if i wasn't president you
wouldn't be getting that beautiful
shot for five years that wonderful
hole-in-one shot so good at best and
probably wouldn't be getting it at all
i hope everyone remembers and you know
what here's the thing
he's not he's not wrong
can we go back to cnn
what is that what is that uh that's troy
junior what is he saying he's never
he'll never go back where i don't know
what he's talking about we do a research
on that
yeah i think we got some right here oh
oh yeah we need to be better about our
background checks wow here at the office
those are some guitars yeah why did the
twins get a background check and not
troy jr
because he's asian for obvious reasons
he seemed like a nice kid um but donald
trump's not wrong
think about this for a second joe biden
every democrat opposed operation worthy
that's why i'm not i'm not anti-vac
people say you're anti-vex look i'm not
anti-vex
at all and i'm not even anti-this
vaccine um i know some of them have been
using uh
have used apparently embryonic stem
cells uh to be developed and in which
case i'm just
morally ethically i'm against that kind
of medical experimentation
um because you can use adult stem cells
right however
i just have weighed the risk rewards for
someone like myself
where the side effects are ironically in
some of the vaccines worse for someone
who's young and healthy
worse in some cases than the virus
itself and i think that older people who
are susceptible like i've always said we
should be quarantining them we should be
locking them in buffalo bill's basement
all old people
out of humanity and compassion um they
should get the vaccines
first that's all it is yeah absolutely
and you remember everybody who came out
when donald trump said yeah we're going
to have this in what october november or
something like that
he said no way maybe before the election
they said no way and they also said
kamala harris i believe we've covered it
several times saying i'm not going to
take donald trump's vaccine
like he was you know pouring beakers
into each other in his basement creating
these things
was breaking trump yeah exactly he's
just reminding people and by the way i
think we've stumbled onto a fun
character you started out in like a
jack black slash donald trump voice yeah
i mean it'd be kind of fun
listen
[Laughter]
my pants get in here um so
yeah no this is uh remarkable that again
this would not happen if not for
operation warp speed because
just let's just look at this really
logically let's be reductive that's
reductive just like i said about women
can't do pull-ups so they shouldn't be
on the front lines i'm okay with it
so let's be reductive with this
operation warp speed meant
removing government bureaucracy red tape
allowing more medical developments to
happen at
warp speed so who typically supports
deregulation removal of red tape while
allowing personal accountability holding
companies responsible
as opposed to having the fda put a
vaccine on the shelf for nine years
because it might give you a slight tummy
ache giving the right to the consumer
and a speedier path to market does that
sound like
a conservative idea or does that sound
like joe biden's
idea there's a reason joe biden kamala
harris and cuomo said they wouldn't
trust the vaccine and by the way
now they want you to all take it
immediately and again i just i just want
people to be able to take the vaccine if
they want it yeah and if you're confused
as to who's
who does this better just point to any
other vaccine in history that's been
developed and and rolled out in less
than a year
just point to one right yeah i have no
idea oh wait is there one
there's not do you know how long it took
to build the uh empire state building
hello do you guys know this because you
remember the world trade center it took
about 12 years for them to put something
up yeah after
yeah empire state building 10 months
yeah someone in the in the control room
can find it there
i might be off by a month or two it was
under a year yeah yeah i mean some
people
some people plummeted to their death
with their lunch boxes well you know
it happens before we we thought safety
is too fast i think
throw enough that's exactly what they
thought throw enough bodies up those 140
story steel beams you get it done
what do you think hit first a body with
a lunch box well our
terminal velocity is reached at a
certain point no matter what just
depends on how quickly they reach
terminal velocity
or no i have no idea that's a good
question is there a drink in the box
because that's it
that's a lot of weight either way they
have a third house either way
you have some time to think about it
yeah that's what i would hate the worst
yeah you just gotta think about it for
you you have to inhale for your second
stream
you know what you're doing
still following i kind of really uh i
should have conserved energy i've still
got a while here
maybe i should take this time to tell
people to put a rope on yeah this
doesn't keep happening
it's a really good idea that we all have
on the way down how about some
carabiners
yeah you have your lunch on the way down
yeah
and this is this is from the empire
state building website it's a little bit
more than
uh 10 months but it was just one year
and 45 days
one year five days all right i think you
guys i think you guys are wrong i think
i might have been the finishing empire
states
i don't care about the crown molding in
the empire state building
could i walk through the building that's
how long 10 months or could you fall
from the very top
yeah you know why do you uh that's a
dumb question why do you think people
scream when they fall
from a tall building i was just like
yeah
i don't know i guess they like ease
there's something to do anxiety like
yeah the anxiety of the whole issue you
know yeah sure it doesn't sound very
easy
they don't look very calm it's releasing
that's what it is what do you want
to do is sing a james taylor song he's
probably the guy's probably complaining
my wife put
mayonnaise again on the sandwich and
damn it sally
first fall in front of the bill that it
did this in my mind i'm gonna carry
along there you go
nope it's carolina lands still hurts
james taylor was wrong um
all right bye-bye holy yeah
cause i'm free free
tom petty was a dick man so
governor speaking of cuomo by the way
let's go to governor whitmer
sometimes it does feel good to be a
little uh actually i don't want to say
good to be vindicated because this is
horrible seniors have died at record
numbers there in michigan michigan is
worse than new york i believe in a lot
of ways
certainly in principle and i'll get to
that in a second but now that everyone's
talking about uh governor cuomo
um it it has brought governor whitmer
back into the spotlight and for people
who don't remember we've been covering
this for a very long time this is what's
so funny to me when
people have been saying with governor
cuomo oh
how did this go on and nobody noticed uh
okay people noticed we know you decided
to tell the stories from
social media and big tech do you want to
know you want to know why people didn't
notice and by people
i mean you you dumb son of a [ __ ] the
reason that you didn't notice not our
audience but the rest of the audience
the rest of people in america
the reason you didn't know is because of
the same
for the same reasons that i've been
suspended from twitter for six days
without any reason or cause
the hunter biden story of him doing
crack with his niece nude in a stand-up
shower at the end as i don't know i
don't want to disperse the
reputation of the end as nice hotel but
the point is remains i'm creating
creating a mental picture for the same
reason that post
was punted from social media you never
know about it because they control the
flow of information people like
us people like uh rush limbaugh god rest
his soul there were plenty of people
covering the cuomo situation there
weren't so many people covering the
governor whitmer situation right but
that's just because not a lot of people
had access to the information
and michigan doesn't come to the front
of your mind when you're thinking about
um major states with incredible
corruption so
it's a state that's near and dear to my
heart born there lived there for another
seven years recently
um i love it i love the state of
michigan and i just hate
the people most of them not all the
people
the ones who elected the lady who's uh
who whose stockings will undoubtedly
roll up under a house
hopefully so it will end on monday
macomb county prosecutor peter lucito do
i have that name right
it's not jacobson peter lucito um
announced that governor whitmer may be
facing
actual criminal charges with clip if we
find that there has been
willful neglect of office if we find
that there's been
uh reckless endangerment of a person's
life
by bringing him in then we would move
forward with charges against the
governor
of course we would nobody's above the
law in this
state especially not when pugly adam's
enforcing it
it's probably too wide of a reference
it's wednesday no never mind you don't
seem like more of a monster's guy
yeah so monday also charles leduff filed
the final complaint
in the case against whitmer um here's
the thing most people know about
obviously cuomo's
nursing home scandal right right um with
even aoc calling for an investigation
and if aoc calls for an investigation
into a democrat governor he must be
doing something really bad yeah
okay that's not us like a little bit
like aoc
is polling everyone in the state party
saying all right have the tides
have the tides turned right let's
investigate cuomo um but a lot of people
don't realize that whitmer
is actually a lot worse than cuomo again
in practice because
her policies uh actually ended up
putting not just not just returning
old people who were sick to old folks
homes young
people young sick people into old folks
homes
here's an episode that we did on a half
a year ago
this is the man who was beating an old
person an old folks home in michigan
more than every year
okay all right that's enough horrible
right yeah listen that's it's still
tough for me to watch today that guy
that old man by the way that old man um
ended up starving himself to death yeah
he became depressed starved himself to
death
pete i remember when we first covered
the story we didn't know that that was
the reason that young man was in the
nursing home covet
i thought it was a worker somebody
beating yeah at some point but no it was
just a it was a guy who had kova that
was put in that was a young guy right
and
his dad said my son should not have been
there he said i don't know how many
balls were dropped
for this to happen my son should not
have been there and while the media was
ignoring
whitmer and fawning over cuomo we were
the first ones to really sort of bring
some national
uh attention to it and by the way see
michigan this one is specifically for
michiganders out there
folks in michigan what what do you think
has happened to your state
honestly i mean people think of the
midwest as the the heartland of the
country
um there's been no accountability for
this for this uh abroad can i say that
um
i mean it in disrespect definitely uh we
even went
and then hold that thought but we even
so for people who don't remember we went
to michigan
and held a rally with thousands of
people and that resulted in thousands
of foia requests which we'll come back
to because it's relevant right now
let me say in no uncertain terms
governor whitmer
her policies have directly led to untold
deaths of michigan seniors thousands
and you have been at worst deliberately
misled
and at best deliberately misled about
those numbers
michigan's tracking and it's the only
state with these comparable states
doesn't include assisted living
facilities
adult foster care facilities or homes
for the aged
in michigan it's 34 percent coming
exclusively from some
nursing homes you know how many those
are
1967 deaths coming from
about 440. how many currently active
licensed facilities are there in
michigan
over 10 times that amount folks i say
this president trump
if you are watching that i and the
people of michigan
all would like to say in unison governor
whitmer you want to conduct that
investigation
and donald trump for mishandling coven
all right sweetheart you
first michigan i love you god bless
let's make it happen
and by the way the only coverage of that
was there were a couple hundred people
who showed up and oh
did any of them try to kidnap whitmer
that was the only coverage so that's why
you haven't heard about it and i've
never done a rally like that ever i just
again i have a 97 year old grandma in
michigan who's been directly affected by
these policies
friends have been directly affected by
these policies and by affected i mean
dead
so uh matters to me and i just
this is the problem with three four
companies controlling the town square
people die sure i get banned because i
uh point out the obvious fact that it's
child abuse to put a four-year-old on
puberty blockers you know tomato no dick
but it can actually get to the point
where information that could save
people's lives doesn't get out and so
you have people
politicians who are no longer
accountable and people
die there was a bipartisan bill in
michigan by the way to put a stop to
this
and she vetoed it democrats and
republicans said you've got to stop
doing this
no under the guise of emergency powers
well you know the reason is because you
care about the seniors that are actually
affected by this and what it seems like
governor whitmer cares about is
her image yes and what people think of
the state of michigan and her job of it
because you know her star is rising or
at least was before all of this happened
uh but if you look at the numbers
according to the cdc per one hundred
thousand so per capita
they're the 11th worst state in the
country in vaccination and they're
blaming the former administration by the
way
as of the time of this article that
we're going to get to in just a second
there were 70 percent of the vaccines
that were sent there were just sitting
in hospitals well yeah so let me so this
is what
so that was back then we were just
talking about the arsenal yes and by the
way you can still go to
lotto credit.com whitmer death toll so
this got trending there were thousands
of signs
put up in michigan where you can submit
your own foia request
right just to find out the actual death
number because it's far higher than it's
being disclosed
we know that it's way higher governor
whitmer just she punted it she said i
don't have to do it why under the guise
of emergency powers okay well those are
going away they were just stripped from
governor cuomo
let's see that happen with whitmer and
then she'll have to at least answer some
questions
but let's go through the misdeeds that
have been committed since then like you
said back then just record number of old
people who she was
nothing yeah and in october she ignored
the supreme court's order striking down
her months of executive orders saying
that the emergency powers were necessary
she again denied the foia requests uh
like i said uh
cuomo has been stripped of those so that
gives us a path moving forward now where
no no you can't shut down churches keep
pot shops open
and not disclose the numbers of nursing
home deaths um
and then here's like i think we have a
clip of what you were talking about
noah if you want to understand whitmer
okay i picture a non-whitmer and i
remove all reason
and accountability because here she is
blaming all of it on
you guessed it you get donald trump the
feds are slow walking
the process of getting the addresses to
pfizer for some
reason i cannot get an answer to
we have michigan hospitals and nursing
homes
ready to administer this vaccine and the
bottleneck
appears to be the white house what was
that
appears we got rainbow okay well let me
just wrap this because rand paul's gonna
want me to point out governor whitmer by
the way
she was wearing she fashioned ted
nugent's guitar strap into a shirt
so she blamed it on trump but once trump
was actually gone
uh whitmer failed to allocate enough
vaccines for seniors she didn't allow
vaccines for 65 year olds until january
11th
and as of january 1st only 25.7 of the
vaccine supplied by the federal
government had been administered she's
just letting it sit there just last
month
she quietly extended restaurant
limitations until march 29th when they
were set to expire on february 21st i
know several restaurants that will never
open again one of which employs 19
people but fight for 15
shut down the restaurant um and she
originally eased up on the restriction
this is what's so
telling she eased up on the restrictions
two days after biden's inauguration oh
wow that makes sense yeah that makes
absolutely uh
sense you know we have a clip here but i
don't want to have rand paul continue
waiting it's just a propaganda clip of
governor whitmer
doing a santa claus thing to try and
teach kids to be communists yeah uh
however you can still go to loudwhitmer
death toll
or michigan.gov we have the site up here
where you can submit
your own foia request simply wanting
transparency
in the actual number of senior deaths at
those facilities in michigan
keep her accountable this is how you
win uh i believe that we have coming up
right now
uh senator rand paul do we have senator
rand paul
i think we have uh someone sitting there
waiting so as we wait for senator rand
paul here again we want to take some of
your questions do we have a stinger for
rainbow
no no we don't okay um senator stinger
like a walk-in song well i was going to
say that uh that uh we can play the
santa clip but instead
let me tell you this is there's several
reasons i want to have rand paul on
first off i
uh he is the candidate i agree with most
who also aggravates me
but you love him why why i just feel
like he does that with a lot of people
uh i just i i don't think there's a
candidate i don't think there's any
politician out there who i agree with
more on issues if you were to do one of
those political compass useless tests
than rain paul
right um but i do and i say that because
you can just see
other people getting irritated here when
he was talking with
assistant health secretary rachel levine
doctor
um uh and providing actual
scientifically accurate medical
information and you can just see the
frowns we have a clip and then we have
senator rand paul
do you support the government
intervening to override the parents
consent
to give a child puberty blockers
cross-sex hormones
and or amputation surgery of breasts and
genitalia
you have said that you're willing to
accelerate the protocols
for street kids will you make a more
firm decision
on whether or not minors should be
involved in these decisions
senator transgender medicine is a very
complex
and nuanced field and if confirmed
thanks for informing the practicing
doctor
i would certainly be pleased to come to
your office and talk with you and your
staff
about the standards of care and the
complexity of this field
let it go into the record that the
witness refused to answer the question
the question is a very specific one
should minors be making these momentous
decisions for most of the history of
medicine
we wouldn't let you have a cut sewn up
in the er but you're willing to let a
minor take things that
prevent their puberty and you think they
get that back
uh it's a trick question i love it they
don't they do not
i love it by the way talk about reverse
logic this was a video that was banned
from youtube at the lgbtq town hall
where they were teaching people how to
transition
children and getting funded by the
government and i asked them if someone's
like i posed to someone who had a
transgender child they said
look you give them the puberty blockers
and then if they decide that they're not
trans you take them off it and they
probably go back it's like oh hold on a
second
how about we do the opposite of that
we are not and how about that doesn't
work the right way he asks the question
do they do
they don't just get that back you put
them on these puberty blockers for a
reason
and what are they making these decisions
at 12 13 14 years old
six even six yeah i was about to say
sometimes even earlier on in
life they're not capable of making this
and all rand paul did was say
i have a legitimate question that
parents across the country right now are
asking by the way it's not just
can the kid make the decision it is at
what point does a seven-year-old get
tied up with an activist group that then
takes the right of their parents away so
that the kid
can make the decision legally even if
their parents disagree that logic would
be like so look you guys have done
uh fitness videos for a long time that's
how he became really popular
strapping young lads um so what it would
be like someone coming to you for
fitness advice right being like hey look
i haven't done anything
what should i do and you go look take
trenbolone
and then afterward if you find it
doesn't give you the results you want
you can just go to you know lifting
weights and eating right right
but you know that's that's between
consenting and adults you know no it's
illegal but it's consistent those
i don't see what's the rush with a small
child they can't even consent
they are not even at the legal age of
consent how could you let a small child
remove his giant tail or a female
and take puberty blocks is just sick
it's just beyond reason it is beyond
think about that that's one thing that
people don't talk about they are not of
the age of consent sexually
but they are making decisions that can
forever change their sex life imagine
this
right it's part of the wonderment of
life when you go through puberty you
know that first time maybe for me it was
that
it was awesome i was like look there's
hair growing yeah i was like
that that part of the jerry maguire tape
got a little bit worn we didn't have the
internet back then
but the point is just vcrs the point is
imagine that you think your parents have
you know have done right by you you get
put on or you get a sex change puberty
blockers
and then once you reach your teenage
years you find out that you're one of
the
significant percentage of transgender
individuals who will never be able to
being achieve an orgasm oh what i would
just man it's no point of living
that's that's what i'm that's why i wake
up i don't think they
yeah i don't think they put that in the
questionnaire go ahead
that's why i wake up in the morning for
what to bust nuts
like a black man busting his nuts oh my
gosh
do y'all have like some merch for that
like
i just don't want to go deep inside okay
all right
this is a family show we were assuming
there was you know corn nuts
that's a good thing
especially if you're doing it in a
circus tent in the ussr on your
honeymoon
why do more people not talk about the
fact that bernie sanders went to the
soviet union for his honeymoon
yeah by the way this wasn't like last
year or something like that this is when
it was really um this is when it was
really bad
it's like going to south africa during a
party and by the way you know that
wasn't his decision
his wife was like i don't know maybe
he's st lou she's like how do you feel
about fighting a bear for toilet paper i
booked the tickets no return
flight all right we have senator i
believe senator rand paul we just showed
that clip of him with
dr rachel levine senator rand paul can
you hear me sir
good morning it sounds kind of crazy i'm
not sure i want to be on
part man it is i'm not sure i want to be
hosting
uh but uh i appreciate i just showed
that clip of of you with with dr rachel
levine first off my question to you
senator rand paul is uh how did it feel
to have
uh someone sitting there at this at this
hearing informing you
of the subtle and nuanced details
of transgender medicine of which i'm
sure you were not privy
yeah i thought you know maybe dr levine
was going to say now son
you know just you can't understand this
and i'll come and talk to you
bless your heart we're just not sure you
can understand the nuances
of giving little kids hormones that
change their sexual appearance
but no i think that when you look at the
actual issue
it's horrifying to think that the people
biden is appointing
would actually say that a 10 year old's
opinion would override their parents
consent
so a parent says no don't get anywhere
near my kid
and the 10 year old says i want to go to
a gender clinic
and all of these people who have already
become activists and zealots for this
many of whom have done the surgery to
themselves are there telling your 10
year old kid how brave they are
and how it's a great thing for their kid
to want to do this and the parents
object and they would take a
ten-year-old's word over their parents
or ten-year-old's opinion see i think
that nobody in america believes that i
think maybe less than one percent of
america actually think that's a good
thing
right but everybody's afraid of the
media because the media will beat the
hell out of you
and say you're a big hater if you bring
it up well yeah you were you were
trending on twitter as transphobic that
day when again it used to be that you
could say
look you want to do you want to put on a
dress put on makeup as an adult do
whatever you want to do
that's fine it doesn't doesn't increase
a libertarian more libertarian-minded
person it doesn't infringe on my life
the only issue is when we're talking
about women's sports but it used to be
and by used to i mean
two years ago still a relatively safe
position to say but you can't let kids
transition they're like oh
no no no no we don't want to let kids
transition the good news is what if she
were to call you son
you could demand some testosterone pills
yeah because that would be some kind of
gender hate crime to refer to me by my
gender at all so
right now i think the thing about it is
is when you talk about this
they're also lying to you they're saying
oh it's all reversible
well there's two different things they
want to do to your children first they
want to delay puberty
there is a certain reversibility to that
drug but when they get to be 14
they give a girl massive amounts of
testosterone enough to grow a beard
a beard better than your beard probably
that's not saying too much
yeah see what i was saying i was saying
this before senator rand paul
is the person with whom i agree the most
and still irritates me
but here's the thing is you give a 14
year old girl that much testosterone
she grows a beard she doesn't go back to
the appearance of a girl it changes
things
forever and a 14 year old can't make
this decision
but they begin grooming these children
at 10
because the so-called psychological
evaluation
is a bunch of people who have changed
their sexual appearance through surgery
or hormones
telling the child it's okay do you think
anybody is at the gender dysphoria
clinic saying
well you may you might be careful this
could be permanent maybe you'll change
your mind
right the american college of pediatrics
has looked at this
and 85 to 90 of these children who are
confused
work it out and end up not doing this if
you leave them alone
don't give a medicine and don't affirm
and
coach them into believing that it's a
good idea left to their own
sort of desires most kids will kind of
grow out of this
there's a large asset it's actually over
90 it's it's it's up to 98 depending
where you i think the source you used
was 90 but that depends on the age you
know where you do the cutoff
it's up to 96 or 98 percent now do you
people don't know this the number of
children who transition if you put them
on hormone blockers
is zero so there's a direct correlation
right there between
intervention which we know in any other
scenario obviously would be considered
medically risky
uh and the outcome of the child
yeah and uh but this is a bigger debate
even just beyond the specific issue of
whether or not
children should override their parents
wishes at such a young age
and to do something that i think is
potentially irreversible
and i think it's really just a crime and
should be considered to be child abuse
and yet these this is being mainstreamed
and these people will be in charge of a
trillion dollar budget at hhs
right so and some of a lot of that
budget will go towards government care
of children
so will this dr levine be able to get
her radical views
into the the minds of children well when
you have a trillion dollar budget
i'm sure this doctor will find a way
yeah but with hhs a trillion dollars is
like a take a penny leave a penny jar
one of my uh co-hosts here uh gerald has
a question i believe
and then we're gonna have to go to uh
youtube only because they don't like
this yes
senator i had a question we have club
only the mud club yes yes
we we have the party of science right on
the other side saying you have to always
follow science follow science well how
can we when they keep changing what
science
is i think isn't that the point you're
bringing up like you guys are not
following the science especially as a
doctor
yeah well actually and nowhere is this
more apparent than all the covid
you know there's been a a million
different opinions by dr fouch he's been
on both sides of every issue
but the one thing consistent about dr
fauci is that when he lies to you
he's lying for your own good because
you're not
you're not smart enough to make
decisions you might choose not to be
vaccinated if he tells you
that herd immunity takes 90 percent so
he's been telling you 70
because he wants to convince you to take
a vaccine
likewise on the masks the reason he has
admitted that he lied
i don't know what the lie was because
her mask probably don't help at all
anyway
but he said he says oh the mask will
help the mess well
but don't he didn't want you to buy the
n95s because the n95s are the only mask
that actually probably works to a
certain degree
that's the one the doctors used and he
was afraid that the public would buy
them there wouldn't be enough
so he lied or you know misspoke or
told you what he thought you were
capable of hearing at your low
intellectual level
and uh this is a problem this is a you
know falci is the the paragon of elitism
and that he knows better than the rest
of us but in a free society it's the
opposite
every individual assesses their own risk
whether you're gonna cross the road
whether you're going to wait for a green
light whether you're going to get in a
car whether you're going to get on a
motorcycle whether you wear a helmet
whether you take a vaccine whether you
get the disease those are
individual decisions in a free society
and we can't forget that and before we
go to mug club only here really quickly
didn't he
mock you on the mere concept of hurt
immunity or am i misremembering that
at every point point that he disagreed
with me he turned out to be wrong
when you examine the evidence and i know
that's a surprise that's a shocker but
i'll give you the probably the worst one
and this one hasn't been publicized in
our first meeting in march of last year
as the disease was just starting to go
through that first peak
i raised my hand and said dr fauci don't
you think in some of these very sick
individuals that high-dose steroids
might work
we've used it in other conditions like
this where the lungs fill with fluid
as a last gasp sort of thing and he says
oh no we've tried that that doesn't work
what turns out the most important thing
you get if you have to be put on a
ventilator
is iv steroids at a high dose to try to
save your life
and it has actually brought down the
mortality by 80
using iv steroids so he's wrong on
everything he's wrong on immunity
he said oh kids you know kids could get
sick and they might have kawasaki's
disease
turns out the death rate among those
under age 25 is one in a million
it's less than the seasonal flu now it's
more dangerous than the flu for older
people but for younger people this is
actually less dangerous than the
seasonal flu
so for young people one in a million
you're saying and there's a chance all
right we're going to go really quickly
to mug club only everyone watching here
send your questions for uh senator rand
paul dr rand paul
uh youtube thank you but we don't know
where this is going so you can uh
um i'll be polite you know what to do
youtube